In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for April 24, on which we commemorate, our Holy Father
Wilfred, Bishop of York.
Having been gifted with divine favors from his birth, Saint Wilfred entered the famous
monastery of Lindisfarne at the age of 13.
This was the center of Celtic tradition in Northumbria, and he rapidly became an object
of admiration for his rigor in xenobitic observance and his passion for the study of the scriptures.
After some years, he undertook a pilgrimage to Rome in the company of Saint Benedict's
Biscope, with a view to study the Roman ecclesiastical traditions.
After having venerated the holy places of the Apostolic city, he was instructed by Archdeak
in Boniface in the interpretation of the Holy Gospels, the Turgical usage, and the calculation
of the Feast of Easter that the Celts of Ireland and Britain refused to accept, and which was
to become the subject of so many troubles in the young Anglo-Saxon church.
On completing his studies, he received the Pope's blessing and set out on the way home, staying
for three years in Lyon, with Archbishop Delphinos, who appreciated him and who perfected
his instruction in the sacred sciences.
Returning to England in the year 658, he was named Abbott of the Monastery of Ripon, and
began to battle ardently for the abandonment of the liturgical particularities of the Celtic
church and the adoption of Roman customs.
After the ecclesiastical synod of Whitby in the year 664, which saw the triumph of the Roman
party, he was named Archbishop of Northumbria, by his friend and spiritual son, Alkfrid, son
of King Osvy.
Susurrain of the Anglo-Saxon Federation, and chose as his sea, not Lindisfarne, but York,
where the first missionaries sent from Rome with Saint Paulinos had established themselves,
refusing to be consecrated in England, for fear of controversy, he went to Gaul to
be ordained by his friend Agilbert, Bishop of Paris.
But when he returned to his country, he was surprised to learn that, following the return
of King Osvy to Celtic usage, his episcopal sea had been occupied by Saint Chad.
In order to avoid new dissensions in the House of God, Wilfrid preferred to retire to the
solitude of the monastery of Ripon, and to leave it to God to do him justice.
Yet he was soon solicited by King Wilfrid of Mercia to consolidate the faith in his kingdom.
After having founded several monasteries and having taught the true faith, he was sent
for by the King of Kent to direct the diocese of Canterbury, which was still without its
bishop.
At the end of three years, in the year 669, when Theodore became Archbishop of Canterbury
and primate of the Anglo-Saxon Church, he wanted to repair the injustice done to Wilfrid,
and persuaded Chad to retire to the monastery of Lastingham in order to leave his sea free
for Wilfrid, which he gladly did.
Wilfrid, taking up the direction of his episcopal sea once more, showed an untiring zeal in founding
churches and monasteries and in educating his people in the Evangelical Commandments,
strengthening their faith by his preaching and the power of his miracles.
After some years of happy collaboration between the Bishop of York and Egfrid, the new king
of Northumbria, the Holy Queen Ethel Drida, who had aided the saint in the foundation of
the majestic monastery of Hexham, renounced the world under his influence, and embraced
the monastic life.
This development unleashed the bitterness of Egfrid, who from that time was set upon the
downfall of the Holy Bishop, profiting from the absence of Saint Wilfrid, the Archbishop
of Canterbury pressed by the king, deposed the Archbishop of York, and divided his diocese
into three new seas in the year 678.
Being no redress from the princes, Wilfrid undertook another journey to Rome, but he was
cast by a tempest onto the shores of Frisia, where he began to evangelize its inhabitants,
thus preparing the way for the work of Saint Wil abroad, and the conversion of Germany.
Arriving in Rome, justice was done to him, but the division of his diocese was maintained.
When he returned to England, after having participated in the council called by the Holy
Pope Agathon against the monotholytes in the year 680, the king of Northumbria refused
to accept the Roman decision, and the bishop was thrown into prison.
Released after nine months of incarceration, he went to evangelize the southern Saxons,
Sussex.
The same day, on which he administered baptism to the leaders of that nation, the last in
England to remain pagan, he put an end by his prayer to a long and deadly drought,
and thereby brought about the conversion of the greater part of the people.
The king gave him the gift of some land, where he founded a monastery for the monks who
had followed him, and for the neophytes who desired to embrace the angelic life after his example.
On the death of King Egfrid in the year 686, his brother Aldfrid re-established the Man
of God over the whole of his diocese.
Coming to the end of his days, the Archbishop of Canterbury, St. Theodore, was reconciled
with him and humbly asked his forgiveness.
Wilford continued to show himself an intransigent defender of the divine law, without respect
of persons.
His adversaries succeeded, however, in outwitting the king, and five years after he was re-established,
they tried again to divide up his diocese.
Wilford was exiled once more to Mercia, where the king confided the diocese of Lycfield
to him for eleven years.
In the year 703, the king of Northumbria and the New Archbishop of Canterbury decided to
relieve him of all episcopal functions and assigned him to the monastery of Ripon.
Once again, Wilford made an appeal to Rome, and leaving for the continent, he undertook
the journey on foot through Frigia, Noestria, Austrasia and Lombardi.
After having thoroughly investigated the matter, Pope John VI and the Bishops declared that such
a shepherd should not be separated from his flock, and they ordered the Archbishop of
Canterbury to re-establish Wilford and depose the Bishops who were occupying the diocese
of York and Hexham.
On his return to England, the Archbishop of Canterbury, accepting the Pope's decision,
was reconciled with Wilford, and the king of Mercia committed himself to respecting his
authority, but, Alfred, king of Northumbria, declared that he had in no way changed his opinion.
Some short time afterwards, the king fell gravely ill, and confessing his sin on his deathbed,
ordered that his successor make peace with the bishop of York.
Yet immediately after the death of the king and the nomination of his successor, the latter
declared that, if the saint did not leave Northumbria in six days, all his supporters would
be put to death.
By the just decree of Providence, this unworthy prince was himself thrown out six months
after his accession, and at an assembly held near Rippen, it was declared that there would
henceforth be an alliance and perpetual peace between the king, the Northumbrian nobles,
and Bishop Wilford.
The latter had, notwithstanding, to be content with his two principal monasteries of Rippen
and Hexum, the second of which became an episcopal sea, and for long years gained the admiration
of the whole of the west by the splendor of its buildings.
With peace finally established, Saint Wilford spent the last four years of his life in
the monastery of Hexum, peacefully preparing himself to appear before the Lord.
He gave his soul into God's hands on the twenty-fourth of April in the year 709, at the end
of forty-five years of a tormented episcopate, which marked a decisive step in the formation
of Christianity and of the English nation.
He delivered it from the particularism of Celtic practice to prepare it for its universal
mission, in particular for the evangelization of the Germanic peoples beyond the Rhine and
the Danube.
Saint Wilford was the founder of dozens of monasteries and introduced the general observance
of the rule of Saint Benedict in England.
He was also the spiritual father of a large number of male and female saints, who left the
court for the peace of the cloister.
His body, first laid to rest in Rippen, where he had worked many miracles, was later transferred
to Canterbury Cathedral.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.